archived document
good afternoon everyone my name is dr
miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today
is scp-3004
object class neutralized
special containment procedures the
threat posed by scp-3004 has remained
neutralized
containment of scp-3004 is focused
solely on interception of artifacts that
point towards the existence of the cate
lady
to that end archaeological sites in
ireland and wales should be monitored
closely
artifacts are to be confiscated
catalogued
and incinerated all scp-3004 related
matters are to be dealt with by the
theology department
director clark is to be notified
immediately if any events
thought to be scp-3004 related occur
scp-3804-1 is believed to have been
destroyed or otherwise deterred from the
material plane
and no longer requires containment any
information found regarding the
existence of the cicada lucilenta is to
be destroyed
and civilians involved amnesticized due
to its connection to scp-3004
description scp-3004
refers to a series of anomalous events
linked to the rituals of a druidic cult
known as the catelagi or the singers
they were located primarily in ireland
during the 15th century to the 19th
century
it is known that their worship revolved
around the life cycle of the now extinct
sicadeta lucilenta due to the combined
actions of various antecedent groups to
the foundation
including the vatican's congregation for
otherworldly acts
and the royal society for the
imprisonment of the abnormalcy
all knowledge of scp-3004 and the
singers was destroyed in order to
contain scp-3004-1
as 3004 was thus destroyed the 3004-1
entities ceased
all activity scp-3004 events
centered around imagery associated with
the rights of the singers
they occurred most commonly during a
celebration surrounding a child's
entrance into adulthood
which was signified by the first loss of
primary teeth
these events were theorized to lead to
the entrance of their deity
dubbed scp-3004-1 into local time
space scp-3004 events are understood to
have been the result of scp-304-1
attempting to act upon the material
world it is unclear as to when scp-3041
began to react to the beliefs of the
singers
while there are signs of varied scp-3004
events
there are a few reports that still exist
artwork relating to scp-3004 events
shows sicadetta lucilenta coming from
the facial orifices
causing asphyxiation in many a written
record details the sighting of an
anomalously large
instance of sycadeta lucilenta believed
to be scp-3041
appearing in the sky the site of which
caused painful boils in those who
witnessed it
along with symptoms resembling radiation
sickness despite this
the singers were said to have continued
their rituals in the face of scp-3004
events which was seen as necessitating
their destruction
scp-3804-1 was an entity which
interacted with the singers through
their rituals
causing scp-3004 events little is known
about the nature of scp-3804-1
it is theorized to have been a thought
form or an extra-dimensional being that
through happenstance
responded to the rituals of the singers
there is no data that exists to point
toward scp-3041
being anything greater than a level
three pistophage entity
archived report j clark
sj
due to the intimate nature of this
subject i
only read this world surely christ
willing know me
and i them and its current neutralized
state
i'm going to keep the academic hot air
to a minimum
i have no desire or need to impress any
of you you're my colleagues
and i think we all understand that
there's no need to hide what is beneath
jargon and posturing 3041 is a deity
if you wish to define a thing as such a
deity is a creature of law
ritual and belief certainly its
existence doesn't shake my faith
nothing has and i doubt a curious
thought form attracted to cicadas and
greenery will shake it yet
it is not infinite and not all-knowing
quite the opposite its limits are
apparent cut off from a few rituals and
direct believers
304-1 ceased all activity
there have been no resurgence events
harriet peep
truthfully what little we have left of
the history of the gate legend
the singers in the vulgar english is
quite interesting
based around the sycadenta luca lenta
and its apparent rebirth and what have
you it wasn't just a fringe druidic sect
this was nationwide they were respected
members of society
there are signs of them in wales and
scotland so of course
before the inevitable violence the
catholic church in its ever ineffable
wisdom
may the lord god forgive me for
blaspheming his one true
church on this earth of course etc etc
did attempt to bring them
into the fault before the complete
eradication of the cateleggy from the
face of history
in an unprecedented act of violence and
usage of anomalous objects that many
would see
as foolhardy maybe even horribly unwise
emilio five council forgive me for this
slight
against the forefather of the foundation
of course etc etc
the parishes in certain rural areas of
ireland
seemed more singer than christian this
is all we know
this is all that is left the eradication
of their rituals
of their culture of their impact on
ireland and the world at large
was snuffed out with alarming
thoughtfulness
not unprecedented certainly but consider
the fact that this happened in the late
1700s
this was a desperate act of early
incarnation of what we all became
foolhardy and harsh yes but i truly
cannot say that we would not have done
the same given what little we know
of 3041's effect on our material plane
of course given the english view of the
irish at the time
it's not overly cynical to imagine that
the royal society
relished the chance to destroy the
culture and the
impact of the categoy so total was their
destruction that
the extinction of the cicadeta luca
lenta charmingly known as the stained
glass cicada
became an opportunity to even wipe their
sacred animals from the memory of man
the deforestation of ireland certainly
led to the death of their species
but one must wonder if their extinction
came from a more
direct source this of course is all
merely speculation
maybe this sacred animal merely followed
their deity
certainly it speaks to the fear they
felt if the royal society in the
congregation
would enact the destruction of an entire
animal species
a harmless creature cousin to the new
forest to canada
perhaps they feared that cut off from
ritual
304-1 would manifest through them the
idea certainly is not ridiculous
there is a strong connection between
belief and fact perhaps
their fear would have even made it so
given the fact that the catelegi were
upright to members of society
one can imagine that the resonance
within their rituals that thirty or four
one felt were
mere happenstance in my opinion there is
no reason to assume that this entity is
at all related to the catelergy and
their beliefs
something in them i hypothesize spoke to
this thing
and acclimated itself to their belief
system
think of it as something floating in a
place close to ours
maybe laid above or beneath perhaps
there are many creatures like it there
i doubt that an entity like this would
exist alone although
i have no proof of this besides their
certitude of my gut
through these repetitions of behavior
through these beliefs it was able to act
on our plane
and it became what it was molded by
there is also no reason to assume 3004-1
to be malevolent
it is disingenuous to think of such an
entity in terms of
good and evil given the focus that the
category had on life and death
along with the imagery of christ the
savior's death on the cross
it stands to reason that the 13041
manifestations would be violent
it spoke only the language it knew the
language of blood
wood glass and sacrifice perhaps the
brutality of its manifestations
of the events associated with the 3004
rituals
could have been the 3041 entity
interpreting the very real subjugation
of the irish people at the time
there was no reason to assume that the
lives of its followers
would not be just as important to the
entity as their rituals
certainly the language of death and
rebirth of the cicada
of the scourging at the pillar present
in the rites of roman catholicism
especially in the era of its
neutralization
and what is theorized to have been the
rituals of the kate ledgie
could have lent to all of the violets to
the harshness of it all
[Music]
faced with their god a terrifying thing
that's so
discord there is no record of their
reaction there is only record of their
destruction
one would imagine them to have been
horrified yet to have necessitated their
destruction they very well may have
followed the entity's whims
however alien no proof has been found to
point towards either hypothesis
but again this is all conjecture we
simply do not know enough to take any
approach to this object
other than making sure it never comes
back i
do not believe that we will be unable to
deal with something like this
given the current technologies available
to us but it is best not to awaken a
sleeping giant as it were
given what we have here i can offer no
other advice
whenever we rarely find something that
our premises is missed
we catalog it learn what we can about
what we destroyed
and move on to other things
[Music]
current document
item number scp-3004
object class ketter
special containment procedures all
communities that could possibly support
an
scp-3004 event are to be monitored for
uncharacteristic rises in death rate and
attendance at places of worship
if a community is shown to have been the
host of an scp-3004 event
or events all afflicted civilians are to
be amnesticized
any injuries or deaths that occur
because of these events are to be given
applicable cover stories
at no point is an individual known to be
involved in an scp-3804 event
to be considered for foundation
employment d-class
or otherwise mobile task force y-99
altar boys is tasked with responding to
scp-3004 events
in progress where possible and stopping
them by any means necessary
all sightings of scp-3804-2 are to be
reported to the theology department
images of 3804-2 are to be dismissed as
hoaxes
or deleted as necessary all instances of
scp-3042 found in the wild
are to be destroyed to avoid future
scp-3004 events
as of project site c logs there are to
be no attempts to track
scp-3402 instances any attempt is to be
made to destroy them
before their disappearance there is to
be no further attempt at contacting
scp-3804-1
304-1 will be contained through cleanup
of scp-3004 events
and the destruction of scp-3042
instances
currently all containment is focused
upon reducing the effects of scp-3004
events
which have already occurred if scp-3041
entrance into the material plane is
unavoidable and inevitable
protocol damnacio adbestius is to be
enacted
description scp-3004 refers to a series
of anomalous events
that occur in roman catholic eastern
catholic
anglican and episcopalian communities
scp-3804 events occur without any
patterns connected to population
or demographics other than religion
while scp-3804 events are varied and
have few similarities to unite them
the presence of scp-3042 at each event
proves a connection scp-3004 events
are rituals carried out by otherwise
non-anomalous individuals
in their place of worship despite
showing a great divergence from
christian norms of worship
individuals involved in an scp-3004
event show great hesitation to stop
engaging in the ritual
even those that involve self-harm all
individuals attending the place of
worship
for that purpose will not stop the
rituals involved
even if their actions go against
previously held morals
individuals who normally exhibit
entomophobia exhibit
no fear of the scp-3042 instances
involved in the ritual deaths that occur
as a result of scp-304 rituals will be
categorized as
death by natural causes regardless of
what was done to the individual
those who witness nscp 3004 ritual
express
a renewed interest in their chosen faith
and seek to convince friends and family
to accompany them to their place of
worship examples of scp-3004 rituals
include the slaughter of a child bearing
traditional stigmata wounds
out of which crawled instances of
scp-3042
the child was killed when the
officiating priest bit
out the child's jugular scp-3804
instances crawled on mass from the
wounds up to six hours after the child's
death
the forcible removal of the officiating
priest's teeth
by 12 children the children and the
priests were then seen to vomit
instances of scp-3804-2
the teeth were served in the place of
communion wafers later on during the
mass
the violent castration of every male who
has reached puberty
scrotal tissues were gathered and
disseminated amongst the faithful and
worn around the neck as scapulars
the castrated individuals then mimicked
the cry of an unidentified cicada
believed to be sicadetta lucilenta
before many succumbed to blood loss
scp-3042 instances were observed
carrying off discarded testes
a visibly pregnant woman was chosen from
the congregation
and brought to the altar where she laid
and proceeded to give birth to over 60
instances of scp-3042 and a stillborn
infant wearing a wooden crown
the crown was burnt and the body
consumed
scp-3804-2 instances resemble the
extinct
cicadeta lucilenta albeit with a much
more colorful
wing pattern than what has been
described despite appearing in every way
alive
scp-3042 instances are primarily made of
wood
and glass it is unclear currently of
scp-3042 instances
are the cause of scp-3004 events or vice
versa
during an scp-3004 event scp-3042
instances are observed in prominent
parts of the ritual
after the ritual scp-3402 instances
exit the church and disappear after
flying at least 600 meters away
this disappearance is hypothesized to be
the scp-304-2
instances returning to scp-304-1
either to feed it or perhaps be given
further orders
it is believed that scp-3042 is the
mechanism
by which scp-3041 collects belief
or faith in order to consume it is
unclear as to why scp-3401 in its former
incarnation
did not seem to require the 3004.2
instances
as of project site-c lux it is now known
that scp-3804-1
created instances of scp-3004 as a
replacement for the cikadeta lucilenta
scp-3041 is the entity that controls
scp-3042 instances and is believed to be
fed by the scp-3004 rituals
scp-3804-1 is a level 6 pistophage
entity
that exists in a dimension that exists
partially within baseline reality
but primarily above it from within this
dimension
it is currently unable to directly
manifest itself
into the plane of existence however if
given enough belief
from the scp-3042 instances
scp-3804-1 will be able to enter the
current baseline reality
which would cause an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario due to the
brutality of scp-3004
events scp-3004-1 views itself as the
deity worshipped under the umbrella of
christianity
due to this it is theorized that the
beliefs of christianity-based religions
especially anglicanism and roman
catholicism
melded with the beliefs of the catelege
in such a way that their destruction
caused scp-3041 to feed on the beliefs
of the only remaining familiar group if
scp-3041
enters the baseline reality protocol
damnacio at bestias will be enacted
this will involve the usage of thalmeal
objects and mass amnestics which will
serve to
erase christianity from the historical
record
cut off from its food supply this is
theorized to be an act that would fully
neutralize
scp-3804-1 addendum
it has been noted that scp-2852 has
ceased its appearance
after the first recorded scp-3004 event
due to the similarities of their
manifestation this is hypothesized to be
related
currently all personnel assigned to
scp-2852
have been reassigned to scp-3004
for the record my name is agent timothy
letterman i'm a member of mobile task
force sigma 25.
we've always called ourselves
ghostbusters to be honest
i don't understand why if anything we
become ghosts
sorry been rambling i'm just coming down
from all that
stuff we pump ourselves with to be able
to get outside still
seeing trails you know still kind of
freaked out from all that [ __ ]
for official record mtf sigma 25 is the
result of project
sightsee which was a project to
basically use astral projection in order
to better
uh contain troublesome skips you know
things no human a drone could ever go
which happens more often in our business
than you guess
project site c lux was utilizing
sightseeing technology
and esoterica to well check out the big
bug
so before i went in i read the report on
3004
[ __ ] up stuff the kind of stuff that
gets your stomach in a knot just to
imagine
you don't understand fear until you're a
disembodied soul floating around and
within and above and below a monstrosity
beyond your reckoning
the method was easy enough i don't know
how they did it but they captured a 3004
too all they did was let it out and i
latched on to it
like well a soul bug not you know
bug as in those things but bug isn't
listening into things you shouldn't
inside where it lives it's empty there's
only it
and then there's the bugs except they're
not bugs as you see them
they're bugs as it sees them and there's
so many colors
they just kind of look like some jackson
pollock nightmare smearing all over the
darkness
but it's not darkness it's nothing this
thing is within nothing i
can't i can't describe it but there's
nothing else but
it and the bugs and me i guess i'd say
it was cold but
cold is a feeling sure cold is a lack of
heat but
this is a lack of anything it's hard to
look at it
that's 3041 but it's too big it's just
waking up
i realized that when i saw it you know
when you half wake up and lay in bed for
a few hours before getting up
i don't know maybe i'm just a depressive
but that's what this thing is
all of it is idle the 3004 events are it
hitting the snooze button and staring at
the ceiling
i don't want it to wake that's all i'm
thinking and then it sees me
it's a big bug and it's an old man and
it's a cicada on the cross
and then it's stained glass and wood
stretching infinity
it's too many things to try and pick up
at once it's like
if someone played all slides in a
slideshow at once
overlapping that hurts so bad to look at
and then it talks and it all hurts worse
a thing you need to realize is that it's
impossible to speak
to these things with words you don't
hold a conversation they
beam thoughts concepts worlds at you
and you gotta sift through this [ __ ] to
get something meaningful i've met some
talkative once but
this was something else this was too
much
it thinks it's a god not a god but
god god who was so happy to see me but
that joy was nothing
i wanted to be part of it was all blood
and teeth
it sees what we have it sees what we
believe
it thinks it's giving us what we want it
it doesn't understand
metaphor it doesn't understand we don't
resurrect
it asked me if i missed it i don't think
we ever neutralized it
[ __ ] maybe we did but when it went to
sleep i think it thought it was a
hibernation or like a birth
like a lady made itself maybe it got to
thinking
it was even more of a cicada than before
and when it came back
it gave us our bugs back it basically
said
you're welcome it's not exactly protocol
i guess to talk back to these things
especially something like this but i
tried to tell it that we didn't want
them then it all hurts us i don't think
it hurt it didn't want to hear it
i feel like it smiled and that was when
its mouth opened
it's hard to explain the sight of it
like a rainbow opening
up and out and inside these colors you
haven't seen
and you'd [ __ ] yourself if you were a
body and then i was a communion host
falling through its maw that was the
wine too it took of me
and it ate i fell through it
it was endless lots of pain
but not the kind you'd be able to
understand a pain of the soul
it was prodding searching me for new
things
i don't think it gets too much from
where it is like looking at a tv with a
bad reception
it was so happy to read me they felt its
feelers all over my first girlfriend
i felt its teeth digging into my 10th
birthday
it lapped up every memory of every mass
i've ever went to
and i went to a lot theology major you
know
probably where they picked me i don't
know why it's alone
father clark's report said this creature
would be one of many but
there wasn't anything else it was too
big for there to be anything else
it was all space and time i think all i
did was feed it
i think i got more ammo from me i don't
know all i can say is that we shouldn't
send anyone else there he can't argue
with something like that
and we know enough don't go back we
don't want this thing to learn any more
than it has
and it has so much history already the
thing i'm most scared of
if this isn't god i think it might
become
it's confident and well it's all there
is
i looked and that was all there was
while working on the ethics committee i
always sought to live up to the morals
instilled in me through the catechisms
of roman catholicism
and it is a very hard thing to be a
roman catholic in the foundation
and outside this isn't due to any
complicated tenets
nor harshness it is trying to believe in
something you know
has caused undue harm it knows it yet
protocol don nacio at besties then will
allow for a cleaner slide
judaism will remain untouched islam will
only lose one of its prophets
nothing too damning but christianity and
all it is done all it is caused will be
gone
i don't relish this i wish it could be
any other way
but the 3004 events are becoming more
common
the big bug sticks its head through the
top soil and we all cut it out at the
root
it's impossible to say for certain what
will happen we don't know if we'll be
undone or if
there will simply be a deletion we don't
know if something will fill the void or
if there will be a world with a great
gap
even then it's better than the world it
will come into being if we stay
the cicada god is coming and it doesn't
know the difference between life and
death
metaphor and smile don't translate well
where it is
part of me relishes what we're doing to
it in a kind of petty way
there is a non-zero chance that that
thing devoured my lord
of course if the lord god could be
devoured he would not be my lord and god
but still
the humanity in me cries out for the
blood of that that which killed him
we will starve it the preliminary tests
have been concluded
protocol damnacio at vestius will be
enacted as soon as possible
and to stave off this devourer of god
we will throw one of our own to the
lions to be torn asunder
and to tear asunder to be damned and to
damn
to act as a perpetual lock on humanity
to stave off all belief even close to
what a cicada can eat
to use the less poetic terms a suitable
candidate
has been contacted a roman catholic
reality bender
ethics would not allow us to put someone
into this situation without their choice
without their understanding of what will
happen to them and he took the mantle
they say the lines are beautiful twelve
machines
each at the peak of techno eschatology
and they really do
look hungry and prone black carbon and
shining metal with
lights that are prismatic no colors that
dazzle
and he will go in between them they will
open his brain
his mind all christianity all that he
knows
and doesn't will be obliterated the lord
god sent jesus christ his only son to
suffer and die on the cross
and we the foundation will throw one of
our own to the lions for all eternity
to undo all christ died for an eternity
of suffering to erase his sacrifice
it isn't a fair price but nothing is
the holy father as you may know recently
allowed for another road
to sainthood this is of course dying to
save others
this isn't martyrdom which is merely
dying for the faith but this is
eternally dying for
all of humanity all that the river will
be and has been
this will be the last and greatest saint
of christianity
and he will not be remembered before the
eternal lions feed upon him
remember for as long as you can the
eternal life of saint jude the damned
bulwark against the darkness hopefully
this
next world will be better may god
forgive me
if this is a sin i will burn along with
the last saint
brandon callahan child of god
i would like to give a special thank you
to
suser hintern zargaran
professor puffer the morrigan
revenant brian sanchez
patrick bailey matthew gilmore
eric corbin kawaii fire keeper
longinus carcass death aqua
king madding james saba
and njvujak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen thank you
you